i don't think there's not too many
people that play play like me and the
playstyle i play with so it's kind of
hard to watch films so i got to watch
myself
on steps and mistakes that i made so
that way i know how they're going to
attack me and get prepared for the next
week
[Music]
micah parsons is in the building what's
up t-rooks how you doing
you know i'm good man i just be
maintaining living life maintaining
living prospering
you know manifest manifesting absolutely
all the things i mean what a
season it has been for you monster
season and we're gonna talk about all of
that but what i have to bring up first i
need to make sure everybody watching
knows
how good you are at games
i've never lost a day of my life never
lost and so
story time i met micah before he was
drafted he was figuring everything out
we were hanging out with st juan we're
doing a game night
me and you
ran the table in taboo
nobody beat us
no nobody is i think we did taboo
and heads up and we were so good
and then saquon wanted you on his team
the jealousy
it was just bad and i told him
it's crazy because now that i got my boy
durong with me
and i told sequon he could have you and
we're going to wipe your nose
you i like this is a thing i'm honestly
being as real as possible there is no
world
where you beat me in heads up or taboo i
am
honestly i think i'm the greatest player
in america
and then you know someone always meets
they they make her and that's gonna be
me every time you know what i'm saying
i'm glad you're smiling right now and
it's good for the show but tomorrow
you're gonna be sick to your stomach
talking i can't believe i just lost to
mike and duran i also can't believe that
you're just like dropping me for someone
else i mean i'm doing it because the
simple fact is i don't want no excuses
from saquon because i'm gonna wipe his
nose too there's a great one you know
they all go oh you're cheating you've
got taylor uh you know i don't need the
best partner well because you know they
recognize you gotta admit out of the
group i'm the best you're one of the
better ones yeah yeah i can't give you
the best title because i'm the best okay
so we're gonna we're gonna do one round
a heads up you're you give me clues okay
okay or do you wanna do opposite what do
you want you tell me um i like uh
a nice little just kidding
or uh
just kidding that's all the worst it's
the simple ones
these are tv shows or
football basketball uh whatever football
basketball be too easy uh superstars
see i don't really know kidding okay
what about pop culture
see i don't wanna i don't like to think
it's that i'm good that's why
and you're good at just kidding that one
is awful that is so easy
wait let me look at it because it might
be something else that i like that i
might have to
tap into
yeah i like
movies of fun tv shows is fun
see you guys see you read a lot of books
too yeah i have the book one
yeah i'm not playing that one yeah mine
is just gonna be just kidding fine we'll
do just kidding
well you're just kidding i'm not going
to be good at this i don't even think
i've ever played it
no warm-up too no we're not good
[Music]
oh what do you have in your hand phone
yeah what is it what type is it
a iphone yeah
um what do you
send to someone when you're trying to
see them
a text an invite yeah a a an evite no
you had it right but that's a message
um
what is red yellow
blue orange right what are you red
yellow what does that mean like a stop
sign a red light
green yeah green light
um
it's a it's a casino in las vegas it's a
uh caesars uh-uh it's it's something
that's like an animal bellagio it's an
animal
it's an animal like it if it it it runs
real fast cheetah uh-uh what type of
casino is a cheetah what what are you
doing
no
oh um it's tall they're old they
you know
you you threw me off it's a flamingo
hotel okay hold on green color of
broccoli
yeah see you are not doing the clues
right what do they need a red light let
me show you how to do clues
okay let me show you how to do clues
this is we're not here anymore okay uh
jack sparrow
of the caribbean
oh uh johnny dip
what is he playing a pirate yeah
uh what do you put when it's raining
umbrella that easy no no uh moby dick
what creature is
yes go
um march of the
it's animal they're black and white cold
um penguin yep
uh what do you put on your neck when
it's cold
uh
in the winter
you put it on your neck when it's cold
in the winter
you put gloves a hat and uh uh scarves
yes
um what it's like a big version of a
tablet
it's also apple yep
um you eat this in the movie theater
butter uh popcorn yep
um you put these on blue
pants blue jeans yes
um you wear this football to protect
your head
[Applause]
[Music]
that is how you give clues those are so
easy quick okay we're doing one more and
we're moving on because you got to
redeem yourself those are so easy i
don't know what that clue was for green
what do you mean it's a red light
red yellow you said red yellow
hey jack would you not get that
yeah red yellow there are so it could be
eminems
okay one more time get it
get it together
i have a warm-up
[Music]
oh some uh something you play uh you
shoot basketball
um oh pom poms cheerleading yup
uh you hit it with the bat baseball yep
uh you warm this up noodles and noodles
and you warm this up in the microwave
yeah
uh you go down this at a water park
slide yeah
uh you go here to get your every six
months for your breath uh dentist
yes uh you use this the
if you want to change something in your
house you might want to change the color
change the color so you
you you stroke it
the lights no you want to change the
house
yes oh she's gonna sell me on purpose uh
girls might wear this on their arm
bracelets yup
um skip that one okay
uh oh it's a square and then think of
geometry square triangle circle
uh oh you're
it's posing pose honestly that was good
there's my partner that first
one
it takes a little warm up that that
person was a struggle but all that
matters is we made it and we're here but
you see you are good yeah i just had to
warm up my brain i was a little nervous
the cameras
you just got to take a little time
i get it well you know that is not the
best thing that you're best at when it
comes to games i would say football uh
is probably the the number one thing
what has this year been like such a
whirlwind for you uh it's honestly been
so fun like tremendous like
and then it also had struggles but it's
been just really great because like the
guys i was around like i've been around
some really great guys some hall of fame
guys so i got to really see
uh how it is to be a pro like at a as a
rookie so i'm glad i got to be at the
drafts of the cowboys really yeah i got
that early stage just watching dag tyron
zack i mean zeke i mean these guys is
all
all pro guys that i got to watch and you
know take a lot of notes from so it's
been cool well you know one of my my
favorite micah quotes
i don't think the nfl is hard
elaborate on that quote
and do you still feel the same
i mean yeah i mean just because like i'm
not saying there's not a lot of talent
but you can't expect everyone to be like
an elite player i would say like not
everyone is elite
so i mean like there's come times where
you face the
davin cooks and
you know the
saquon barclays and stuff like that but
not everyone is darling cooker saquon
barkley
and you know i think once you put the
time and the work in everything starts
to slow down i think everyone will say
the same so i mean if you're coming out
partying all the time and things like
that and you're sluggish and you're not
really taking care of yourself the
league might be challenging or hard but
i mean it could put the work in and you
know you put the mental reps into it i
mean everything will slow down for you
and it got to a point where i'm like
like
i'm here too you know what i mean so
once you build that confidence i mean it
got pretty easy from there so you're
saying it's like your preparation and
your talent that made it easier yeah
through that time and when you're facing
the elite players what makes a player
elite to you in your match-up i would
say how dynamic they are and like what
type of challenges they face for the
defense like
when you playing like an alvin kamara
it's so easy to take like a line back
out the game like someone like me
because i would have to be the cover guy
so they'll take me out and leave
somebody else in
or just something like that or like
someone who can run and but also do
routes like
those guys is always create problems
because just to match up like you want
the right guy on them and then like you
might want to turn and protect like
just a lot of the defense will just key
on them the most so uh those type of
elite guys i mean
and sometimes like
you know some people don't get kids who
you would think get kid yeah
so but there's certain guys that would
get two or three people coming their way
rather than just
oh we know you can win that matchup okay
so then for you you obviously you know
you did your thing every game but who
was that most difficult matchup this
year i would say davin was definitely
like a big matchup for me there was like
one time he put his shoulder down like
oh shoot like he hit two sides like the
next time i had to get back at him so i
said dalvin debo of course like that was
a game where i just felt like i was just
running non-stop
uh anytime you played a mobile
quarterback and i was stuck spying like
kyler
i mean yeah look at him like he creates
a problem for us just because like
instead of you can blitz five like how
we would do for someone less mobile but
someone who could get outside the pocket
i got to stay back and like kind of like
watch them and things like that those
type of things that create problems for
the defense isn't it wild quarterbacks
now yeah in the job that you have trying
to contain them when they are
the movement it's it's insane like that
changes your job too yeah like if we
play josh allen i'll be stuck spying
like guys who can extend those plays get
outside of pocket and just
hurt you downfield i mean
and you know average plays around three
seconds and those guys
they will stretch it six seven and that
creates even more problems yeah
okay so said didn't think the nfl is
hard but tell me
one thing you were wrong about the nfl
something that you thought
it was that it turned out not being
uh i probably thought like it was like a
family thing like i came from a college
and i was thinking like it's gonna be so
much like family like so much more
tighter people but like
really it kind of get lonely in the
league bro like you kind of like
don't really have nobody
and it's like you kind of have friends
that you have at work outside of work
like you might have like one guy or two
guys that you might really just hang out
with
because at the end of the day it is kind
of a job for everyone yeah when did it
hit you that it wasn't that way and it
is like kind of lonely
um all through camp was fun because we
was all there together not a knock start
so i got really close with a bunch of
guys
but
right around that jalen smith thing
happened
i was like yo like and smith was a guy
that like i was looking up to yeah and
you know he was a vet in the room and
i was just like kind of like that yeah
because you are somebody who
super outgoing you have your friends you
love your friends i know you loved like
that the penn state environment
what has that adjustment been like for
you has it been difficult have you
gotten used to it yeah i kind of got
used to it i got my brother staying with
me and stuff like that
but honestly dallas kind of got the same
environment with the football
environment in that aspect like their
feds is just as crazy as penn state yeah
and you all have the craziest fans like
probably in the big ten i would say yeah
especially at football games yeah is
this how you saw your career playing out
like when you think of penn state micah
this rook a year for sure i'd be lying
if i didn't like you know obviously i
had my own goals of what i wanted to do
and i was like competing when other guys
do it like jason noe of course like
we just had a lot of
discussions i was actually with him last
night and you know it was kind of like
he was streaking streaking was both
streaking and like you just turned up
like he's like i was like
i was like you was on my back bro yeah
so i mean like uh
i always like found football kind of
like my thing yeah no i love that answer
because i think
you should be so sure about a town that
you have and you have a vision of what
that talent is going to bring you in
life and what that path is
and there's some things that we expect
to happen to us i don't think there's
anything wrong with being like oh no no
no i knew
i was going to be this once i got into
the league but the thing is you just
can't say it to everyone i keep telling
people that like you kind of just got to
keep it to yourself you don't want that
ego that confidence someone thinking
like oh this guy thinks he's this
so like for people out there like keep
your dreams to yourself cause
you know people could take it for
arrogance like oh who does he think he
is he hasn't really did anything like
he's new
but really like
i tell myself every day to myself yeah
like what i'm going to be how i want to
perform like
how great i want to be yeah but now that
you're here and you feel like you've at
least proven it to some some extent this
season you feel like you can say it no i
still want to say it okay no you just
said it i i mean no but i'm just saying
this in general yeah i won't say it out
loud like
you know i don't want to give no one no
reason to put a mark on my back on
anything you know what i'm saying i mean
you know that mark is on your back next
year
teams will treat you differently
they have they have a year tape
it's going to be a different ball game
next season that's fine yeah i got
overcome i mean it's that's the part
about playing multi positions like you
could game playing for me at rusher
that's cool you ain't playing me at and
but like i mean eventually like there's
gonna be a time where i get a one-on-one
you know yeah like you can't find me the
whole game
and you know that's the thing i like
about i play around so much talent too i
got d law i got randy so it's not like
i could just be the focal point or they
could go off you know it's not a selfish
game that's what i like about football
for sure it's not just you
you did a story with uh the abc in
dallas and you had a really good quote
uh that i want to read
you said why stay at a 99 when you can
get to 100. like why wouldn't you ever
want that extra one like if we're both
99 what would be the difference between
me and you great quote
are you at 100 now
no okay i like
a hundred is like the
impossible because i don't think no
one's like perfect
but
if you strive to get to 100 it just
keeps the the hungry
like i stay hungry like i can never be
complacent like
i got to be the best at everything yeah
so
in what ways can you improve
specifically you individually
what are the leaps you can take next
season
like i was instinctual but like
instincts only take you so far like
there's a couple plays that i missed i
was like damn like i could have had that
like if i were to just you know
watch more third down film or like watch
more second down film
or watch like
it's kind of hard because i don't think
there's not too many people that play
play like me and the playstyle i play
with so it's kind of hard to watch film
so i got to watch myself
on steps and mistakes that i made so
that way i know how they're going to
attack me and get prepared for the next
week okay so all of this stuff is really
like what you can control yeah okay
primetime actually taught me that i was
in elevator i was like what did you ever
do he was like bro the best way to get
better and the best way to know how
people gonna attack you is to watch
yourself like what are your weaknesses
so that's kind of like like when i'm
watching film i'm looking at myself like
what was my steps like was i
slow reading like you know did i play it
too fast too slow things like that dion
i feel like is such a good
mentor uh for for younger players right
now what are some other things that he's
told you that has stuck with you bro
this was actually one time in uh florida
and i saw him in the elevator i was like
dang prime time like and he and that
quote stuck with me and i was like in
high school bro
really
yeah
so he said this two years ago and this
is the thing you're thinking about all
the time yeah
anything that someone dropped something
on me that i'm like dang like that was
some crazy stuff right there i always
keep with me and i tell other people
because i think it's so cool so i assume
you've spoken to him since though like
you
you have not spoken it down since this
elevator
florida time no
oh my gosh you have to connect he's the
best you should go to one of the hbcu
games i might yeah
i have nothing else to do yeah okay so
who do you look to in the league right
now for that mentorship
uh honestly i'd be looking at like one
person
there's no person or no other teams but
when i was at the pro bowl like i met
chandler jones he was kind of like
teaching me some stuff and he's like yo
do you realize you're doing this i was
like no i don't do it he's like i've
been seeing a lot of people doing it's
been effective it's like i'd be
fostering sometimes
i know but you went back and you're like
you know what he might be right about
that
yeah and i was full of stuff when i
looked at like some of these films yeah
and things like that and i think that's
one thing i think there's not like a
envy league like everyone is so
supportive of each other yeah and you
know love to see each other eat like
everyone's like man i'm so happy like
you had such a great year like you
wouldn't be small things like that so
yeah uh i kind of like that stuff yeah
and you you did have a great year
obviously a big conversation right now
about
defensive rookie of the year versus
defensive player
of the year where do you fall on that
conversation uh i would definitely try
to
take the claim on uh defensive regular
year even player of the year is tough
because tj watt did have a crazy year
those last three games he went just
berserk yeah he was hungry for it you
know so i wouldn't be mad you know what
i'm saying and uh i'm just happy to be
you know for right now i'm happy to be
in that conversation but
speaking of like next year i'm
definitely going to be gunning for it
you know yeah
it's also just wild to think that you
were able to accomplish this as a rookie
like you realize the numbers you are
putting up are
abnormal for some for someone year one
see i don't be thinking that like
remember those things that expect like
i kind of like
wanted to expect to do that
so like you know anything but like a
great performance for me i feel like
i just had a bad game yeah like it was
crazy like someone was texting me it's
like why are you so mad like people
don't sound like bro like
i'm not doing all that i want to do out
there like i like like you kind of see
on the sideline x traded like bruh and
then they started the program it was
like he was like why are you so mad like
bro it's not even about that it's like
more my standard yeah than anybody else
is like good is okay for some people and
i'm fine with that but it's not okay for
me yeah like you're holding yourself to
that and that's like what's going to to
keep pushing you
because if you don't no one else will
you know and that's kind of what i told
you i was like bro you got hold me to
the standard that i like to hold myself
to yeah
13 sacks this year which one was your
favorite
i would say the one that broke the
record the raiders game
so so mad we lost you know you kind of
get it to a third and 18 on thanksgiving
huge play
break the record and then it's kind of
like
dang
yeah lose anyway off of p.i that's
horrible and it like takes away how you
can celebrate because you can't be
talking about it because you lost the
game yeah like
no momentum just
that just that just hurts the gut
yeah
which quarterback didn't you sack that
you won a sack
who kyler murray
i wanted him so bad oh i'm so bad
he would have tied uh javon curse's
record yeah you were close i was real
close and then you know
uh
he's like he's from texas too
and like i was at the pro bowl he's like
you have four quarters to get me and you
ain't getting me i was like so mad i was
just like
so you're like oh i'm coming oh yeah i
was like bro i hope we play y'all next
year i hope
i hope i run against you sometime soon
yeah you talked about it a bit but tell
me more about why it was so hard to get
kyler in that game
like he was just
so like dynamic
like the way he can extend plays and get
rid of it like he has great pocket
awareness yeah
like
he's definitely like a top five
quarterback in my eyes oh okay now you
know if you're gonna throw out a top
five you gotta say who's in it those are
the rules for sure okay right now top
five uh
i would say
my homes
and then i would put josh allen second
then i'll put like rogers
rogers might be ahead of josh island to
be honest with you okay roger's my homes
josh
i ain't gonna put it in order because
it's just so hard it's just a five okay
but then i would say kyler
and then i would say like my fifth ones
like tied at fifth
because like they've been through a lot
this past year would be like lamar and
dad
no joe burrow no
why doesn't he crack
the top
joe's like extremely good
but like
some games
joe would like have a day but in some
games like
he's not there
tell me more about how you know when
those not there games are happening
against the bears
he do like i don't know i wouldn't say
it's easy getting his head because i
haven't played him and i'm playing him
next year so i want this to get to him
and he'd come out here down to
18 stadium and throw for 400 and be like
he said that in an interview so i don't
want to say nothing crazy but
i would just say like i don't know i
think he's passed i think in the
playoffs he's been tremendous yeah like
but there's a few games early on that
like
i don't know he kind of said it was the
confidence in his knee which i believe
it like yeah and you kind of saw like he
wasn't trying to run
mm-hmm
and things like that but i think he's
kind of over that hump
so i'm i'm gonna look for it next year
but i think he's a top 10 quarterback
for sure for sure and he's climbing the
ranks like but to just throw him in the
top five already it's kind of like crazy
it's a bit crowded at the top yes the
quarterbacks in this league and i didn't
put brady in there because obviously he
retired yeah but actively so that's like
my top like five six right there
definitely i mean what joe burrow did
last game
that is when i said no the future of
what these quarterbacks are going to be
and specifically the future of joe
burrow i think it eventually will kind
of be
joe's league no joe his you know his
personality his everything he cares
carries himself really well uh i
definitely think he's definitely a
player that i like yeah and you know
he's hard not to like
yeah okay so people say this all the
time but i saw you say it in an
interview when you talked about read the
man not the ball
elaborate on how that helps your game
and also give me an example of what you
mean by that so read the man not the
ball so linebackers like
when you're watching tape or whatever
you're doing
look at the running back like what's his
death versus when he's running the ball
or versus he's pass bro
and i guarantee you look at most backs
like they're back maybe a yard behind a
quarterback especially in shotgun like
inside zones yeah okay now you look at
the tackle as a rusher
like
and his tendencies not people know about
their tendencies like unless you watch
yourself and they might switch it up
like you know
ghosts like tyron smith and lc told me
like they switch it up depending on who
they play
um maybe his foot is just dropped back
like it kind of digs into the ground
just a little bit more
and when the ball is about to snap maybe
his hand jumps back first when the one
he knows he's about to go um
maybe like
you know
he might get a three point versus two
point on pass versus run and things like
that just like depending on the player
read the man not the ball it'll help you
just get a better start yeah and no
anticipate anticipation versus pass or
maybe play action he might try to reach
block you versus just regular set back
i think that's what some people don't
realize when you talk about football iq
it's really those little things it's
like really knowing your personnel
knowing your opponent and that's what
really separates you in game play and
eventually just in your career in
general okay i'm gonna throw out a
quarterback and you tell me
something they do you're reading the man
okay okay
we'll do kyler we talked about kyler
what are some of his tendencies
he counter like depended on the pass
rush like he's very pass rush
anticipated like if it's heavy rush like
you saw the ramps
he's kind of more like
one reed but if he doesn't feel anything
he's kind of like progression reading
derek carr
uh derek carr
it's hard for me to say that because i
play edge that game okay
so i got to be more like edge rush
but
one thing about him he was way faster
than i anticipated him being
okay when did you know this
it was like it was like a third down and
long and he like got outside the pocket
and he dipped off and he was like in a
stunt
and he got the first and he was like
hyperbole i was like
he was moving yeah okay it's only been
one season obviously but is there a
quarterback you feel like you read a bit
better than the others
oh
probably hanukki
okay why'd you laugh
because i i didn't want to do like a
division rival but
uh definitely hanukki for real okay why
um
you could tell when he he gets flustered
and then when he does that he kind of
like holds the ball just a little bit
more like gets unsure of his reads
yeah you know so kind of like you know
when things ain't going right
it's definitely not like
and it's easy for you to explain that
because you know you're man
you are somebody who
is very used to winning and you have
been a winner most of your life so
how do you deal with losing how did you
deal with cowboys first round exit
right like that it was like
it was like a motion but at the time
like i felt like i'd done everything in
my possible way to win like
and
like i wasn't emotional at first until i
realized like who all had the chance of
like losing like around the room
and
that was like really tough for me
because like
you know as much as like
as a rookie like you're like man i can't
wait for the season to be over like i
didn't expect to go out like that
and like
you know there's all this stuff on
social media about the cowboys like
that's one bad thing about the cowboys
when we lose everybody happy we lose
like
so it just builds up inside like
i think next year's gonna be a different
type of hunger for me like
especially around that playoff time like
i was kind of nervous for my first
playoff game but now that i know the
feeling and what's it like yeah and i
think
you know
everyone needs that one feeling that
defining moment in life where
they get that bitter like loss that
gotta try to put like a fire inside of
you yeah
dak did an interview and he talked about
that loss and he said honestly i'm still
not over it i actually think it's gonna
be one of these games in my career that
i think about
forever is it like that for you
uh
maybe for him his pressure's different
you know
uh
you know as the leader of the team
like
he has so much right on him
like no matter if it's a if he don't
throw for three passes or something like
people like man what was dak doing
and
it's kind of like a failure for him
because as a quarterback thinking about
like all the defensive plays the bengals
made but it kind of like highlighted joe
burrow mm-hmm you know what i'm saying
like that defense held them to three
points that
like
but it was played focus with joe burrow
yeah so you know when you're like the
face of the franchise
and
you got so much ride on like your career
and they don't talk about how much you
make and
all those things that really don't
matter
things that don't matter who cares how
much someone makes they can play
football they can play football
and
you know i think
that game stunning for him yeah and you
know i think we all realized the talent
we had on that team and to go out like
that was just
just awful
so what words do you give jack you know
as his teammate you're seeing what
everybody's saying you're seeing
probably what he's feeling what do you
say to him
a guy like that you don't gotta say
anything
like that would probably say something
to you
like that's type of guy that is like
dag is such a like great leader
and such a motivational person like
however much they that man been through
he always finds a way to smile like put
smiles on other people's faces and like
you don't got to tell doc to work you
just see him work yeah like and walk
throughs that has a full sweat or in a
sweatshirt like walkthroughs like he
doesn't have a way to slow down in his
mind so like people like say oh well
dak didn't do this well the way he works
i i have full confidence that like he
will get it yeah and like
it's so early on like dax 28
right
i'm not sure how it is but about that
he's about my age yeah
stafford region super bowl at 32.
like
people like patience is a virtue i would
say mm-hmm like it ain't gonna be one
pivotal moment that defines that career
yeah like he has a such a great
opportunity to bounce back yeah and i
would say you know sometimes we do these
things like we make
decisions about people
really early and we let seasons define
people but i do think on the flip side
though
if we're okay with letting good seasons
define people i do understand why
sometimes people also allow
the opposite too i don't necessarily
agree but i get the the thought process
yeah and i think that's like that with
everything though yeah dude because i've
been judged you know pre-draft people's
all these kids so mature like things
like that but i think everyone deserves
a chance everyone deserves opportunity
like no one should be defined by who
they were before
or i mean we'll all be in shambles but
yeah it only works for certain people
though that's the thing that i hate the
most like
you know
like when
say got injured like people say oh my
god just
just give it time like you know
they people forget that things happen in
life that we can't control totally
uncontrollables so you know you can only
control what you control mm-hmm so i
that's one thing that you know i really
hate that people do like i've never
judged someone yeah and i mean you
mentioned sequon i think that's a really
good example i always talk about i think
about saigon and i also think about
odell
so many things in sports it's all
situational
and it's circumstantial
i barely know o'dell but i'm so happy
for him right i met him like maybe once
or twice while i was would say
and
you know i saw his situation and i saw
the media just eat him up no it's so
damn so damn he's just a bad guy he's
he's all about himself
or anybody who knows him no one ever
thinks that yeah he's like a great
teammate everyone really likes him and
i'm just so happy he's with the rams and
i
honestly like
you know
i'm not gonna i mean i hope he wins the
super bowl you know and i hope stafford
wins and i hope always got one i mean
vaughn all those guys
you know not just because it's the rams
but just because like you know they've
kind of been
a whole bunch of team it's a team
where no one believed in them
you know and i believe in the underdogs
like
no one believed in stafford it was like
oh like what's the hype about staff but
you know he
he's showing you yeah no one believed in
odell he left there and now he's showing
you he's back to doing his thing no one
believe in bonnie's he's older or
whatever killing it bro yeah like
everybody who says like
they're just underdogs which i love bro
makers he came back off of kids quick
quick that was insane
yeah
i just love that stuff because like
those guys never wavered and they just
worked
that's one of the things though i love
about the super bowl matchup is it's
kind of a storybook win for whichever
sally but there are so many people to
root for uh on that rams team yeah okay
speaking of situations i have to ask did
you know the rule about handing the ball
to the ref
i didn't know
i can't
besides defense i can't tell you no off
like besides two minute format i can't
talk about no offer like situational
football unless it's defense yeah i mean
that was such a wild sequence like walk
me through
you're on the sideline and you're
looking at it like what are you thinking
i saw the ref hit him i'm thinking we
might get a second back and then just
like call a game and i was just like wow
yeah like my mouth car just dropped and
i was just sick
yeah as you shoot to my stomach it was a
sick way to lose
and like that's a thing i feel like if i
was a player and i was thinking about
the game that's the moment that would
really like run through my head
constantly
i just think one thing about
dallas specifically is the expectation
every year is championship or a bust
like if you all aren't winning the super
bowl
everybody feels like that year was a
wash like there's very high expectations
do you feel those expectations
uh
we was actually talking about this on a
pivot about the expectations and
um
and it kind of like
i don't feel it because like i'm not in
a situation like i feel like when i'm
putting on my jersey i'm putting on my
pass like i'm gonna ball out regardless
of the score like i don't care if we're
down
thirty there's a way that we could come
back you know what i'm saying
and you know people forget fall groups
like this was just a four what they were
five games five six games last year
and now we just won what 12 this year
yeah so i mean the growth the potential
the talent we got around the team like
the strides like
it's hard to go from
you know a to d
yeah yeah it's a journey like you're
getting like look at the bengals like
there was a it was lose lose got it in a
super bowl
so i think we're taking that step
forward too
and i think for dallas like
the lights are so
bright there
everything is big just because it's it's
such
it is america's team right when did
those lights feel the brightest to you
uh
i don't know if i ever really felt them
like
every big game i wanted to be that guy
in the big game like
i don't think like if you want to be
the best player on the field the lights
never affect you you affect the lights
like
the light is going to shine on you
regardless like the lights don't yeah
i'm saying no absolutely you are
you were not a product of the
environment the environment is a product
of you so i knew as i go
they go
yeah you know because
at the end
they're watching you
so why would like
the pressure of them watching you like i
knew i was prepared like i knew i was
ready yeah i knew the mentality i had to
take into the game
that's why any big game i want to be
like i was there like you and that's how
you remember
you know
people don't remember you by just one
game like
and i tell anybody like you could watch
the tape there's not a game where i felt
like i didn't give them all except for
that new england game and that's when i
was like bro everything got to change
you felt like the new england game you
did not give it your all i didn't and i
i felt like i was just not there i was
non-existent yeah why do you think that
was
i didn't make the plays that i i like to
make like i didn't have like tfl no sax
no like major i didn't impact the game
yeah i feel like
if you're a first round pick or you a
million dollar player whatever however
it may be you gotta find a way to impact
the game yeah have you read relentless
like tim grover no
you'd like that
he talks a lot about that there are
coolers cleaners and closers and
everybody is like one of those and
people that are cleaners they just
operate at a different level every
moment for them is clutch time like
every moment for them it's not like oh
fourth quarter you turn it on because
it's never off um and tim grover he he
like trained michael jordan he's like a
mental
coach and he has a lot of books that are
like that i think that you would like to
read i'm going to get that book for you
because yeah no i think i think that
you'd you'd really enjoy that um couple
more things i wanted to ask you and then
we have some some fan questions for you
that are people watching on the app are
still doing that rocky do you have
questions okay cool um
i want to know also what it was like
being on hard knocks i like hard knocks
but i'm like you know the camera's there
though yeah did you like it i did like
it okay and you know i like the people
too like yeah like they were really good
people and shannon the one that you know
does all the hard knocks is like a very
close friend of mine because she did my
hey rookie so i kind of knew the cast
already
and you know they always treated me so
well
with so much respect so i didn't mind
them being there you had a lot of good
moments like you were definitely
tailor made for hard knocks remember i
was watching it once with me and uh
great when we're texting i'm like he is
meant to be on the show well you know
you know i always wanted to be actors
going back to our acting days yes oh
that's another thing i have to say we we
have these game nights you love games
and one of the games i just like
randomly made up on the spot we gave
each other dramatic situations and then
we had to perform like a monologue or a
dialogue and we were paired up and we
had the best one
you can kind of act i'm not gonna lie
like i could i could i could go i i
could like i've been i've been thinking
about doing a little bit of acting lady
down the road for real really yeah
because our scene it was like
you were dying on the floor and i'm like
trying to save you and you
killed that
i was i was good you're not talking
about how i was really the good actor
but you were really good
yeah no idea don't like me did you go
ahead be trying to start trying for the
next black panther so oh i see that for
you
okay wait if you had to pick like okay a
movie world and a tv world okay that
you're like this is my acting i could
get in this role and kill it tell me one
movie and one tv show um
one movie
bro i'm a big denzel guy
denzel washington's my god
so if i could get into like an equalizer
or a john q
which is a classic for me no john q
that's a hard one like he killed that
like john q was like like denzel's that
guy for me like like i typed his name on
google and watched every denzel movie
really yeah the hurricane was so good
too you ever watched he's he's great oh
my god that hurricane about like the
racism
the overcoming the change of life the
belief in those people who have fought
for him like that just i don't know he
knows how to kill any role any role like
catalog ex
like it's insane senses like yeah he
just
you know i will say speaking of denzel
because uh i remember i was watching an
interview that he did
and somebody asked him when you look at
your career what are you most proud of
and his answer was the career like i'm
proud of the longevity and what i've
been able to reduce and i think that
with the football player too right when
someone asks you what you're proud of
you don't want to only
think about one movie or like one role
that you had you're gonna be like no i
was this
the entire time and that's why i think
that when you're talking about legacy
and what you want to be remembered as i
want to be remembered as being micah
parsons
the entire time and really never letting
up
and i would say you always want to
remember like the turning point
like what changed for you like
and i think that's where the most
successful people come from yeah there's
always a turning point in your life like
if i had a chance to sit down with
denzel i'll be like man what cause he
talked about like i watched his
motivational videos too all his speeches
and stuff talk about the woman in the
barbershop but after that like after she
said that like what changed for him
inside of him for him to become so
successful you know those are the
questions like that i like to ask like
what changed for you like what made you
get that motivation did you go back like
i mean he did go back because obviously
he's very educated now yeah but like you
know what triggered for you after that
like was that the changing part of like
those words of confirmation do that for
you or was it just like
you just got one day i was like bro i
gotta do better what was your turning
point and do you think it's happened yet
so
i always tell this story because
you know people should learn
um at seventh grade i was not good at
school i didn't really put the effort in
like i was always going to summer school
things like that just being dumb not
really caring like i was like i just
play sports like yeah i did wrestling i
did baseball i did football like it
didn't matter to me as long as i was in
a sport as long as i could do that i
didn't care
so
it was a big i was a big-time wrestler
growing up so all my friends was like
getting held back and stuff so i ended
up getting held back
and
everyone was like making fun of me like
i was like getting bullied for getting
held back like even growing up like
always through high school people like
oh you're so dumb you're so dumb
and it just fired me so i was like bro i
gotta make a switch so after that i was
like bro i could never fail again yeah
like i could never fail again like
there's nothing in me that could ever
want me to fail again to make this feel
this type of pain this the cylinder just
feel like empty you know what i'm saying
so after that i was like bruh like i'm
gonna prove all you're wrong
and i'm gonna grind like
i never even got like like even if i got
a c like it scared me like i would never
even try to see yeah
you feel like you proved them wrong
uh
nah like and it's funny because
uh
you know
it's just
it's like at one point it's like you
want to prove wrong
but i was like no like i don't want to
prove them wrong no more i want to prove
myself right
like i want to do this for me not though
okay i love that you know what i'm
really kind of thinking about how we
gonna get
micah and denzel together we got y'all
got to sit down yeah that is something
you got to figure out i sat down with
ray for like an hour over dinner a
couple weeks back that was great
you know
it gave me a nice couple of clues for
next year i can't give you
right here cause you're you're may 26
right yeah so we're about gemini's may
22nd uh-huh do you have two
personalities i have so many bro
i might have more than two i might have
like eight what are they
uh like i got three names for them
right now so it's micah of course
um you got the late night sochi that's
what i'm off you know the henny the
tequila you know late night
and then i got like this angry one that
like pops out but it's so hard to pull
him out like what's the name
i don't know i might call him mad max
yeah okay late night slashy micah and
bad max yeah cause like
it would take you so much to pull him
out of me because like i hate being like
that okay and then like i got this like
pessimistic person inside of me too that
i need a name for
what do you mean by pessimistic
like you ever just feel yourself like
everything's going so right but like you
try to find ways for things to be wrong
and like you kind of put it on other
people
that's kind of like what i'd be doing in
my head like like there's people that be
nothing but nice my butt man they like i
don't know i can't trust him like yeah
they're so like something's so shady
like but like i feel like i'll be
tripping like i'm just going crazy or
something oh no
so that's one of the
the many that you have so then
which
personality of micah is on the football
field
i would just say that's the line
the lion we we up to about five yeah the
lion do we have like a do we have a
happy one besides late night sachi i'm
happy right now that's probably like
because you know i'm always people say
you're a character so that's probably
just me and you you absolutely are okay
all the personalities
all of them are great i love it um
questions
from the audience
okay
if there was one running back in the
history of the nfl you could stop in the
backfield who would it be want me to
repeat it
if there's one running back in the
history of the nfl that you could stop
in the backfield who would it be
bo jackson
good luck
but he was a he was a menace like you
know i feel like and you know they had
the big bars the boss i liked the bars i
watched the documentary
his big thing and when they had that
moment on the goal line
i wanted to win that moment crazy crazy
i mean he is so good i mean do you say
best athlete of all time easily yeah i
mean it's i don't know and he's just
he's that guy just the what if but if he
had that technology and things we have
now oh my gosh different absolutely
different okay i love that what else we
got on hard knocks you said we will be
in the super bowl within the next three
years
how much do you really believe that and
if so what are you doing to prepare for
that
on hard knocks you said we will be in
the super bowl for three
in three years
do you really believe that a great
question by the way whoever asked that i
do really believe that i just like i see
the guys around me and i don't see none
of them like
like
all the guys want it it's just a matter
of we gotta have a clean game like those
penalties hurt
like
there gotta be a turning point in the
game and you know those penalties just
kept putting us back so if we clean the
little things oh my gosh the sky's the
limit i'm gonna tell you this right now
because i know how these interviews tend
to go with me someone is going to clip
that
and if you're not there and i guess what
two years now
they are gonna run the tape so you
better make sure you live up to that
because that is what we call a guarantee
in this biz
you got it you want guaranteed money you
want to win again
[Laughter]
okay uh how many more like two more sure
okay
um
what would you say was the hardest part
you had to overcome during the season
physically mentally
hardest thing you had to overcome this
season physically mentally whatever so
actually like the whole season i've been
battling like a knee injury
so uh
i like i don't know like during camp i
had
i was making a tackle it was against the
rams when we had that practice thing and
i like hyperextended my knee
and it was just like
it was just at a pivotal point it was
like bro i'm in a position battle like
um
i'm going against you know jaylen i'm
like the first games coming up soon
and i was like bro like this is the
worst time for this to happen like
and
it was just something that just kept
lingering because i like you know when
you hyper extend something it needs rest
it was like i can't take no rest so the
whole season like i just have caviar to
get rehab rehab rehab so that way i can
stay on the game
on a scale of one to ten
how much were you feeling that this hurt
when you were playing
i mean you know you pick a little pain
pills yeah you know during the game but
after the game like i'd be like bro
yeah
and this was season long season long
wow
okay
another one okay last one who are you
going to be training with what does your
off season look like in the off season
um and who do you want to work with
who are you training with what does your
off season look like my off season is
probably going to start right after
super bowl weekend um
stop drinking stop doing those things no
more late nights
no more late night sashi
uh
and really just start getting ready like
i want to get more explosive i'm going
to do some work with a little bit
everyone i'm going to work out with
chandler a little bit work out with dee
white a little bit because i love the
competitive environments like you know i
don't ever think it's good to work by
yourself
i think it's good to always work with
someone because you always got someone
that's going to push you to eliminate
you're not willing to go and sometimes
it's not about you pushing me it's about
i'm gonna pull more out of you and
that's just gonna make me better because
i'm gonna try to get the best out of you
and i'm gonna just have to beat the best
out of you mm-hmm
i love that and where do you where do
you spend the off-season so last year i
was in la and that's the thing about
what i got thinking about over the next
week i got to find a place to work out i
got to find a place to train all that
stuff because i've never done it before
yeah there's all the things i know
bernie gonna get you right though yeah
running well bernie will but you won't
see me no miami i promise you that he's
the worst i just think it's too easy to
get distracted down i don't know why
people ever try to do it yeah it's just
there's a lot going on although you
could maybe say the same about la but
it's a bit more controlled in l.a i feel
like and i would like you stay out of
orange county or something like you got
to drive to it yeah there's some
separation between ellie's big yeah the
party and the fun well you know i hope
that you have a very fun super bowl week
whenever i say that you guys are like no
it's not fun because i'm not playing in
the super bowl but you should just soak
in truly the accomplishments that you
had this year that you're up for some
big awards you're in the conversation
for even bigger awards and this is this
is just the beginning of micah parsons
so enjoy that and have an amazing time
thanks t yeah and thank you for stopping
by of course i told you i got you
anytime anytime appreciate tonight
[Music]